depending on the size of the
organization obviously um uh
it's very common um that other team
members will go to the leader and say we
don't want to work with that person i
mean that that's usually a big highlight
you know um
that's frequent um
uh you can tell in meetings uh very
often if somebody um is domineering
but i'm also a great fan of peer reviews
quite frankly
the the army rangers dealt with this
they called them spotlight rangers
when when candidates were going through
ranger school
they had to in the past they had this
issue where these very talented
ranger candidates and the t and the
instructors love them
so they look like they were great
candidates the problem is as soon as the
spotlight was turned off
they were horrible people
so leadership didn't know
and so they implemented peer reviews so
now you have to be good at your job your
instructor has to like you and your
colleagues have to like you your your
and so um and by like i mean respect and
you're you know you you're seen as a
team player and help each other out so
um if all you're doing is reviewing
annually someone's performance
that's insufficient there needs to be
regular feedback mechanisms um um and
there needs to be an open open dialogue
and peer review 360 review where you all
come into a room and you get to give
each other feedback in real time
but yeah it's probably because there
aren't enough metrics
we can't force people um you know the
old joke um how many psychiatrists does
it take to change a light bulb you know
one but the light bulb has to really
want to change
um
uh
three of you have kids
[Laughter]
uh um
um so they have to they have to want it
because if they're resistant to it it's
it's not going to work out um and so
having those conversations all about
growth you know which is which is you
want to create a a growth mindset in the
organization which was we're all here to
be better versions of ourselves so i'll
go back to that 360 technique that we've
used um
we take a team could be two people could
be ten people it doesn't matter 10
probably would be too many but
just because it would take forever
um uh
um
and what you do is you have everybody
write on a piece of paper
um three things
that they believe are their weaknesses
or the places that they need
more growth
three specific examples they have to be
specific examples
then they write three of their biggest
strengths or things that they believe
they've grown the most again three
specific examples
and then all the answers are collated
and shared amongst the teams everybody
can read them then you come into a room
together
and you take turns where first you read
your biggest three weaknesses
and then everyone in the room can add to
it
and uh we give a little speech before we
do this which is we come together
and do this because we're trying to help
each other grow and we all have blind
spots we all have things that we don't
understand or don't see sometimes we
don't realize how we're coming across
and so the people in our your teammates
are going to tell you things that's very
uncomfortable for them to tell you they
don't want to do this
they would rather not do this but
they're going to do this because they
want to help you grow
and so the only thing the the because we
all take turns the only thing you're
allowed to say
is thank you you can't ask questions you
can't push back you can't justify you
can't react you can just say thank you
and if you go thank you we like we shut
that down pretty quickly um and the
reason you say thank you is because i
need to know this our rule is is that if
you have an emotional response if you
get angry or you get uh um
annoyed or uh it's probably true
um if you have no reaction you don't
have to you know if they're just like
no that's not me you can then you can
ignore it you can say thank you
um but if you have an emotional response
it's probably true um and we go around
and it's it's an amazing space cause
like i think i have an open door policy
i think i'm approachable
but
turns out i'm not as much as i like to
think i am and so in this environment um
the most junior person on our team had
an opportunity to tell me that there's
something that i do that makes their job
more difficult
um i didn't know that and in this and
she was very nervous to tell me but this
was a safe space in which she could